[Music]
my name is Alicia I'm going to talk
about how we're thinking but about
evolving our existing platform to
incorporate data lineage show of hands
anybody who knows stitch fix awesome ads
are working great so a little bit of a
little bit of information about stitch
fix where a personalized styling service
we we style men women we have Plus Sizes
that started some time ago and recently
we launched the kids business we've
founded 2011 by our CEO and co-founder
Katrina Lake and since then we've been
we've been working with our clients and
styling them and that's been our sort of
business motto we've been we've employed
about 5,800 nationwide that's a probably
an earlier figure than what I can
remember but and that's the sort of
consistent number four of our strengths
at this point to summarize the business
in a nutshell would be algorithms plus
humans so you as a client would come
into our system tell us who you are tell
us what you like in terms of preferences
in terms of what do you like what he
disliked in terms of clothes in terms of
whatever fitting you want and from that
we want to infer and understand who you
are and style you better
so imagine think of it in a simple way
of finding the pair of jeans that you
want to you want to love and wear pretty
much every day so that's our job to find
you that particular pair of jeans so the
recommendation system understands who
you are takes in your input gives a
recommendation out to a human stylist at
the end who may review it and look at
look at the recommendations that came in
front of them and say oh you know what
David looks better in this top in this
shirt in this particular jeans and they
may choose the recommended recommended
solution or go with something that they
want to override with the Preferences
and so finally we get we get you that
that five items that we want to send you
and it comes to your doorstep you can
choose to keep it you can choose to
return it based on what you like or our
goal is to make sure that you keep all
the five items we send you a little bit
about me I currently work
stitch fix the data platform team my
particular sub team works in the
computer infrastructure side so things
like our data warehouse our spark
infrastructure presto I'll talk a little
bit about it in my talk but our team
specifically manages the interaction
with the data warehouse itself I used to
work for cloud era not too long ago
where I focused mostly on MapReduce and
SPARC I've been a contributor to few of
these projects when I had the time
before and that's that's a little bit
about me who here is thinking about data
lineage or at least wants to do
something about it at least okay it is
what I like and I was talking to Rick
about it it's it's it's a common problem
I've talked to other people I've sort of
gained their feedback and how they've
implemented or their versioning of it
and this is sort of our take on it and
how we look at it and how we want to
implement it we're sort of still
building this out this is not fully
fledged built out yet so we're thinking
about how to evolve and I use this word
of all because we already have this
existing data platform that's built out
there self-sufficient or data scientists
so how do we sort of think of it as
injecting the necessities for data
lineage that you need from this data
platform so what I want to cover in this
talk is talking about what our ecosystem
looks like for our data systems talk
about data lineage at its basic level I
want to talk about why why it's
important for us and what kind of
challenges do we see and I'll give you a
little bit brief on each of those things
then I want to talk about the evolution
and this is particularly how do we how
we plan to approach the problem and how
do we how do we actually want to change
the ecosystem to adjust for data lineage
we have an architecture that we have in
mind that might be changing in a few
months because we're actively solving
different problems in our infrastructure
but at least the approach sort of stays
consistent and at least at least some
time for questions if you have and
certainly we can always meet up in the
office hours if you have any other
additional questions let me start with
talking about the data ecosystem that we
have it's a bit bit of a unique setup
if you look at the bottom you can see
the job execution framework which is
called flotilla which is an open-source
sort of containerized framework fact
it's an abstraction layer on Amazon ECS
and it allows data scientists to write
jobs right tasks that are scheduled and
you can kick them off with currently we
have different workflow engines we're
experimenting with air flow we used to
come from the sort of Jenkins world and
an invisible workflow scheduling and
think about flotilla being sort of the
the job running framework for pretty
much everything around the ecosystem
right in the center lies our data
warehouse which is backed by s3 and we
have the hive meta stored particularly
to hold all the schema information for
the tables that includes metadata as
well which which we can get and insert
any other metadata we need associated
with one particular hive table I wanted
to start right from the top if you look
at if you look at the top and the green
bubbles that's the data ingestion
pipeline which is essentially our Kafka
based system that captures all the event
data and writes it into the data
warehouse there's a whole blog that's
written out by my colleague who explains
a little bit more in detail about how we
started thinking about data ingestion
and how do we how do we go about
building that and the database snapshots
are daily snapshots of post quest
databases from our engineering peers so
think of all the data that's coming into
our data warehouse comes from these two
sources and additionally there are ad
hoc sources of course but these are the
main two larger sources of data that we
collect on a daily basis and everything
beyond that happens as a result of
transformation or any kind of changes
that we want to do to the data after it
arrives and that's mostly run within our
team itself so the uniqueness of the es
way back with hive meta store means we
can play around with things like spark
and presto so going into the spark side
we have clients and we have readers and
writers that are written to talk to
spark now the spark client mode or the
spark client way is more traditional
sparked submit submitting the jobs
through an EMR black-backed
infrastructure and
on the readers and writers side it's
more our and python-based clients that
allow you to talk to spark and in this
way we've sort of incorporated Apache
levy to to make it a bit more faster to
interact with the data warehouse but in
once I think of think of the spark
client to be more long-running ETLs
long-running jobs more production and
the readers and writers could be
something smaller something ad hoc and
something something that needs quick
results so that in mind that is our
spark side coming to the bottom that's
our presto infrastructure and the nice
part is we we don't have to worry about
writes in terms of presto and it's a
like spark spark does reads and writes
into our data infrastructure but for
presto we use that for ad-hoc queries so
that means any data scientists wants
read something quickly or any business
partners who wants to access any sort of
data so we use looker sometimes to allow
business partners understanding a little
bit more of the data themselves so
that's that's interface and it's backed
by a presto cluster we have clients to
allow you to run presto queries in your
Flotilla infrastructure or your local
machine as well so coming to data
lineage itself in in a traditional sense
and I particularly love this slide
because it gets me gets me to presents
things like this
the lineage will be coming from sort of
think of it like a parent-child relation
coming away from the top in the more
Harry Potter side of things it might be
more like grandfather child grandchild
in the Game of Thrones section it might
be a little bit questionable but I'm not
judging its think of it as the same
fashion lineage itself traditionally as
you would think about it and but in the
data side it might be more simpler so if
I have to sort of bring it to a basic
basic explanation you would think about
it as data source getting transformed
read written in whatever way between the
services and then getting written to a
destination so how do you see the the
lineage capturing that we want to do is
sort of this journey of data coming from
the source
what transformed it what what sort of
changed it and then coming down to the
destination now this can be extended to
infinite services and everything that's
particular to your organization but if
you if you bring down to a basic model
this this is some way we could explain
it and this is what we want to want to
achieve at least by understanding the
source the transformation and the
destination itself now why do we care
about it and what what do we think is
going to be sort of a roadblock and some
of the challenges I want to highlight
some of the key terminology that we use
we think of a resource as hive tables -
with the structured data and one of the
Postgres databases from engineering to
think of those as resources that you
have - you have to think about in terms
of sources or in terms of something they
are accessing a job in our world as a
service defined batch job which can
perform either a read or write event on
one of these resources an ID would be an
identifier for either of these jobs so
that you can understand which which
which particular job of which a
particular application is running now
these could be service generated or
synthesized on the fly based on what you
need and an event in our world would be
a simple read or a write of a resource
so I wanted to highlight these before
jumping into what we're talking about
and this this is sort of the catch-all
for all the the resource oriented
changes we need to do or at least the
goals we want to achieve with the
lineage so to begin with think about it
as visibility like why did they data
scientists need to have visibility on
the resources that they're maintaining
particularly if they're if they're sort
of cross if they're cross teams
maintaining different and sharing
different resources within the within
the team then they need to be knowing
sort of the dependencies of a resource
and to make it into a single sentence
what is upstream and downstream to a
resource so it's a resources depending
on ten things and it's and it's feeding
other ten other different resources you
need to know that the effects of changes
particularly let's say you move to a
different team which kind of frequently
happens between our teams if they're if
they're different projects involved
you're sharing different resources
you're inheriting some different
architecture you end up you end up
thinking or what can I
do this particular thing I need to
modify it in a certain way but the
understanding that you have it's kind of
lacking at this point to understand what
kind of change and what kind of effects
it would have so think about staining a
schema for resource and then it breaks
tiny tails down the stream and you're
wondering in the middle of the night
what changed and what happened so think
of it schema changing datatype
modifications and things like that that
you do without an awareness of what
actually happens and what sort of sort
of the repercussions of what you did the
third part is a bit more it's a bit more
sort of tracing long term understanding
of the resource and it sort of ties back
to the initial definition of data
lineage it's understanding how this
resource got here like the source to the
destination and the path of what jobs
written from it and what were actually
happened during that journey and sort of
stitching that context of what what
actually means for lineage for this one
particular resource and I sort of split
this out to another section is debugging
imagine waking up and like ok we get
page but you don't know what to do our
tracing oh this particular job failed in
this pipeline but going back and saying
oh you know what I don't know which
particular job actually failed but
having this sort of graph or at least
having that sort of lineage of where
this came from along with the job and
what resources it touch that will help
you understand and debug things better
so let's say you have corruption in data
or any kind of investigation that you
want to do in your pipeline this would
sort of aid that that ability that you
you want to have at least giving you
more control on your own pipeline and
the last part is a little bit more
historical holding information to
understand how the trends happened
within this resource how often was read
was it read and written into so let's
say you don't need something you can
look at like sort of the historical
information oh we written we haven't
written to that in two thousand since
two years so why or do we really need it
we can sort of do some sort of data
quality or some sort of clean up based
on that information this is sort of a
pictorial description of what what I was
just talking about I'll think about it
resource C you're looking at some things
that are upstream to it and then
looking at things that are downstream so
having that sort of understanding what
is upstream and downstream will be
really beneficial for understanding the
health of sea and any kind of changes
you want to do to resource sea itself or
even the other the other resources
themselves which which gives you an idea
what the dependencies are expanding a
little bit more on the on the
traceability aspect in our world this is
pretty much a common pattern that
happens a parent job sort of quick saw a
child job which essentially reads from a
couple of different resources and this
could be a little bit more as well but
take a single example of a spark job
reading from a couple of tables and then
writing into another table itself so now
you've sort of created this dependency
between a and B and then C and then
finally let's say it extends even
further if C is written or read from
another job and then written into D and
E you're looking at more dependencies
being added so that sort of relational
dependencies that you need to build is
something that we need to interpret out
of this job and sort of at this point we
can't do that in our existing ecosystem
we have all these tools we have all of
this written down but sort of stitching
that contextual information of where
this came from
is sort of the the difficult part we're
trying to solve and understanding where
let's say you read a different resource
but written in that in a different job
then you lose that context so if you're
written in the same job how do you
understand it happened the same same
particular session or same particular
job one of the challenges that are sort
of sort of the larger challenge I would
that's why I wanted to highlight this
was more consistency so think about it
in a more diverse world we we still have
enough diversity coming from the data
injection pipeline you have things to
deal with in the spark side the Presto
side so different multiple services that
are involved within the data ecosystem
and you're trying to change the or
understand the representation of jobs
like think about it the representation
of a job is different in presto and
spark maybe some parallels between what
it comes from what the source or any
other information related to a job but
how do you extract some of the points of
concern that you need and extract the
information that you need out of that
particular job of a particular run that
you already had
and that is something that we're trying
to solve at the moment we the nice part
about maintenance for our team is we
have control about all these clients and
all the libraries within it so there can
be changes that can be done within our
ecosystem to sort of get get past some
of this but the the approach we want to
take is more needs to be more simplified
or at least needs to be more streamlined
so that we can understand what exactly
we're trying to get out of these out of
these services and these job
representations and I want to start
talking about a little bit about the
evolution that we want to do of the
existing data ecosystem that you saw
earlier essentially I want to describe
some of the changes that we're planning
to approach this problem so - first and
foremost is sort of simplifying the data
model of what we're collecting at the
basic level what we want to know from an
event or from a particular job is who
owns it what is the job itself what what
ID or any kind of identifier it might be
having what parent job sort of
originated that job and what exact event
did it do did it read or write a
resource so at the basic level if we
understand this and we can understand
and for more from just just by
collecting this and any additional
information we might need we can
understand that by experimenting and
looking the data that populates into
into whatever data store we take to
collect this information and this is
this is sort of a little bit more
descriptive of that a user or owner of a
team basically owns the parent job and
they initiate a service which is which
is running a job and that either reads
or writes any resources and similar for
another service within the same parent
job so think about this sort of this
sort of example of a single of a single
parent job that kicks off a bunch of
other jobs and how do you maintain
context and how do you understand some
of the some of the ownership and the
read and write relevance of each of
those jobs within that same particular
context of the parent job one of the one
of the easiest thing or at least the
this the the nicest thing we can do is
sort of augment some of the existing
clients and existing libraries that we
had so like I mentioned we have a little
bit
control them but more flexibility to do
it in the backend so the goal is to sort
of not disrupt any of the data science
workflows or any of the any of the stuff
that's ongoing in our systems things
have to pretty much run 24/7 365 so the
idea is to not disrupt some of that
workflow and continue doing while sort
of creeping up keeping up these things
that we have we have to do to inject
extra code and for lineage so the one
sensitive thing that we might want to
take care of right up front is avoiding
kind of breaking API changes if there
need to be anything that needs to be
changed in sort of an interface that's
interacting with the data scientists you
need to be up front and tell them and
communicate well so that they're
prepared to do any kind of changes
necessary before you migrate over to the
new code so the sort of policy a little
bit more hardline is that you don't
change interfaces unless they're
actually really important which is which
is sort of a solid principle
engineering-wise and it's it's a nicer
because you don't have any kind of
existing burden of maintaining Stauffer
ography if we don't if you don't do
abrupt breaking changes the the other
part is to essentially augment the
existing tools and libraries and I'll
talk about in the architectural phase
talk about what we're planning to do in
each of them but the idea is to sort of
inject some of these this extra
information extraction from from what we
need out of this out of the services and
extract the information that we need
from them then the even more nicer part
at least on the spark side even on the
presto side is some of the libraries are
pretty back-end and so the clients only
interface to them so we have a little
bit more control and we can change
things and I've I've done that in the
past week we've I've changed something
and was testing it so it can be easily
done and introduced without a lot of
pain but the the effort is again to be a
little bit more careful and be more more
item portent in the workflows that they
are essentially they data scientists
expect a certain behavior and certain
function within their workflows and
keeping that consistent it should be
always be the goal so even if you're
extracting information making sure that
things work the same way is something
that is that is called at the
or pretty necessary I want to go over
some of the architecture we thought
about how to implement this and you in
the in the data ecosystem that we
already have so we have a lot of Latin
references in our in our ecosystem so
I've picked this name for our internal
tool for data lineage now whatever it
shapes ups to be but Salton seems like a
nice name and this is the nicest photo I
found with the guy so I keep using it
and this is sort of the the idea we have
about how to how to implement something
like this at the basic level think of it
as four stages extracting information
collecting it doing any kind of ETL work
we want to do and then finally pushing
it up to the users who want to gain some
of the information out of that out of
that sort of relations that we develop
so in the data acquisition phase think
of it as collecting data from your
existing tool set piping it down to an
intermediate storage that could be in
our world high pack by three and then in
the third stage you're thinking about
how do we interpret this data how do we
do any kind of relational relational
analogies understanding what we actually
collected is it sufficient do we need
more information to interpret something
can we get enough contextual information
from what we already have what do we
need more things to run and I'll explain
some of that in a little bit but the
understanding at least what I think
about it is the first three stages are
going to take pretty much 80% of the
time if not more because just
understanding that we have enough of the
data sufficiently to interpret lineage
in this context might be bulk of the
work and then pushing it up to data
scientists or any kind of use end users
might be might be a latter step that can
be configured upon later so the goal is
to at least get a clean version of what
what relations we need to explore and
like at least we come down to the point
where we can consistently tell what
happens to a resource on a daily basis
or even even a dynamic view of it we can
we can sort of mark it as oh we've we've
done enough and we can experiment
further in the later stages a couple of
splits on data now data acquisition at
least the traditional approach we want
to take is the event
so think of it as firing off an event
off of every job or any kind of spark
spark read and write into into our data
ingestion pipeline and we do this for
most of our applications think of the
think of it as a as a logging store and
we have an HTTP endpoint and enables us
and we already have we already started
collecting some of that information in
the writing so we know which table is
being written to and which sort of
partition has been written to if it's a
partitioned hive table and we sort of
want to take that same infrastructure
and reuse it for this purpose rather
than building something totally new and
and sort of waste wasting a lot of
resources that may not be needed but we
can always use the infrastructure that
we already have and one of the nice
things we have at s3 sync that allows us
to write into the hive tables we can
specify the schema and those write into
the hive tables we had to do a la
there's a library that sort of converts
some of those raw files into into hive
but that's sort of a pipeline that we
already have working for us and we want
to reuse that so again sort of going
back to the approach that the clients
will send some of that lineage
information over to the data ingestion
pipeline we call it the data Highway and
we can collect them into whatever store
we want in this case would be like a
hive table on the schedule side I put
this up here because at some point of
time if we fall short of something that
we didn't collect or we collected and
it's not sufficient out of the
event-driven side we're thinking of
having something like some ad hoc
process running and collecting more
information that's missing so think of
it as getting more query information
from presto or any kind of other
information that's sort of sort of fall
short of what we're collecting at this
point so think of like flotilla logs or
any of the container container logs that
we might need to get more context of
who's running the job like you can get
so much with environment variables but
if we fall short then there's always
this sort of backup or last resort that
we need to run because we're falling
short of some parameters and understand
in our understanding of the context for
data lineage so it is going to be a bit
more harder to maintain I don't like
that approach but I want to call it out
because it might end up being a extra
solution that we might need to add but I
hope we don't come to that come to that
stage
so look at what our event-driven
pipeline looks like so think about
firing an event of read and write and
that goes into our data injection
pipeline and we can pipe it down to any
other any hive table we have an elastic
search that elastic sync that that
allows us to write their or index it but
for now I think we can do much more with
our hive tables itself in the second
stage the intermediate data collection
we're again typing it into the hive
tables so think about going back to the
earlier data model that I explained what
we need to collect from a resource is
the database name the table that it's
getting written to and this paradigm
called batch ID which is essentially an
epoch timestamp of the version of the of
the data so what we do is add that batch
ID of the epoch timestamp after every
write so that we know that this is the
current version of the table or the
partition that he wrote in to so if we
ever go back or sort of want to want to
go back to an older partition where you
miss some of the data you can always
rewrite and write into a different batch
ID into s3 so that's worked out pretty
pretty good for us and we we sort of
consistently want to maintain that on
the service side we want to collect
again the job the owner of the parent
and actually the service names could be
spark or presto or any other ad hoc
client that's writing out of it let's
say you're writing from your local
system or of little o backed environment
so understanding that more caught more
context within where you're running it
from could also be used used for
understanding where the job came from
under I want to dive into what what
exactly were tiny thinking about doing
in each of these services on the Presto
side we have some of this implemented
already but we're extracting the
information given to us right presto
itself like so some of the query event
that gets generated we're sort of we
added like some custom code and piped it
into our data ingestion pipeline and
sort of keep a record of what queries
are running and what sort of schema is
being touched and essentially
understanding who's writing it so
there's enough contextual information at
this point there but some of the missing
pieces is again that tying
with the with the parent and child and
from relationship so we know what presto
query is fired but we don't know where
it came from we came out maybe it came
from the service but where did you where
did you start that was what is a
flotilla container was it your local
machine we're doing some sort of testing
in some other machine so getting that
getting that additional parent
information helps you tie back and
saying he'll you read it from this
because what I what I thought about well
while thinking about this was imagine we
you read something from presto but you
save it in spark you sort of mist that
mist you created a dependency now that
we're not aware of so yes Presto's is
good for reading ad-hoc but what if you
use that to write into into the data
warehouse into a table to spark so you
sort of missed that link between both of
those that they happen in the same sort
of job so to maintain that we have to
collect sufficient information from both
and then sort of tie those things
together there's a lot more work on this
side of things on the spark data lineage
the what we're currently doing and this
is sort of a lot of things are in flight
at the moment the we're actively
changing how we're executing in
deploying spark jobs I have a whole
different presentation about how our
spark infrastructure works but we're
sort of changing some of that aspect and
we used to rely on particularly the geni
infrastructure coming out of Netflix
which is sort of our redirection layer
going into our EMR clusters and we're
sort of changing and taking that taking
a different approach and using more
heavily in the flotilla infrastructure
that we already have so think of drivers
running into in a container and then
kicking off executives in into our EMR
clusters so it gives us more control the
bootstrapping is not not as crazy as it
is with genie so a lot of improvements
in that sort of execution phase that
we're going through at this point the
the second part is more adding more
information I mentioned where we're
looking at a lot of the the writes at
this point but we're not focused a lot
on the reading of data through spark so
any any sort of conceptual contextual
information of reading is sort of
missing in that in the current world of
spark for us so we we of course you have
our own version of spark we we forked
out at the open source libraries but we
need to we need to augment
some of that to make sure that we
collect the relevant information and the
nice thing is before interfacing with
the data warehouse every spark job hits
our internal library and that library
allows us to read and write write data
into the data warehouse along with
updating the the hive meta store with
the latest information so think of it as
updating the latest location of this
table into into the one that you just
wrote into so we the third part is
something I'm more excited about I
recently finished a sort of
experimentation of getting park' into
our mix and sort of getting to getting
to a point to move over the park' at
some point of time so this sort of
experimentation worked and it kind of
its kind of a nicer way to do things and
hopefully in the future we can we can
talk about it more and how we how we
moved into Parque but I want to do a bit
more testing be more be more pragmatic
about it and see how we can approach it
in the best way possible because we have
enough we we have enough control on
those libraries that can allow us to do
things and finally again the approach
again echoing augmenting some of those
clients the SPARC clients that we have
and adding more logging or adding more
information like extracting where it's
run from so think of it as running from
your local machine think of capturing
something like a hostname or an IP
address or something that ties back to a
user and say oh you know what the users
local machine ran it or any kind of
environment variables that you can run
from the machine that it that actually
executed it and sort of the third stage
is more refinement and this is more sort
of not defined well at this point
because it's more ETL based extraction
depending on what the data were sort of
in the phase of the SPARC lineage at
this point so implementing that might
end up solving some of this and like
getting all the information but the ETL
work would come once we collect all that
data so once we have enough of their
information getting that into a cleaner
state into a press into a Postgres table
and finally servicing that users might
be it might be a later stage but at
least the first stage would be to
collect all that information and one of
the things I think would be useful to
collect more would be aggregated metrics
like over the over the course of the day
how often was a
or touched or how often was it read
about and also the main thing would be
the resource relationship so though the
upstream and downstream relation I
mentioned something that that is of
paramount importance we need to get that
first but in addition to that the
aggregated metrics that we can extract
from all this information we have would
also be useful to surface some of that
into into like a trends of dashboard or
something like that like how how often
was our data in infrastructure touched
or how often is our warehouse interacted
with and finally some of the user
interaction portion is where I'm
thinking and this is more more abstract
at this point this is some of our some
of our early early thoughts of how it
should look like it's essentially
showing a view of a resource you want to
see what's upstream and downstream to a
certain degree you can go we've been
back further if it's if it's even more
if it's even more deeper in the tree and
understand what's what lies beyond a
single a single edge and then going
downstream and understanding oh you know
what I'm breaking ten of these other
things and this sort of use case is
really useful if you're if you're
actually doing any kind of hardcore
changes on any of the enemy ten of the
resources and to understand the
dependencies of all of them at once
gives you a better idea of doing that
change so let's say you break you do any
kind of breaking changes you make sure
that you go down to the downstream and
make sure those each shells work and
those are tested well if you're changing
any kind of aggressive things like data
types that's you're expecting a string
but it's an int that you've changed into
your you're sort of changing that data
model according to your perspective but
you're breaking ten things down the
stream that that you don't understand so
at least giving that giving that
interface to data scientists would be
helpful and in the more static views
thinking about metrics for the data
warehouse I mentioned that earlier it's
understanding the health of the
warehouse and understanding the
resources we already have some of the
access logs into s3 and we see whichever
objects are kind of being kind of being
looked at but that's not sufficient
information it just gives you a sort of
sort of gives you a request URL and
understanding where it came from but
tying that back to an actual job or
anything like that is sort of still
harder in the dynamic views you're
thinking more in flux more sort of
intraday changes to a resource like
let's say is
resource was written ten times during
this day with ten different partitions
so some tables I've seen are partitioned
every ten minutes and so that's a lot of
data coming in so tracking that
minuscule changes is also important oh
let's say we piped in more data from
another table that's something we need
to know dynamically on a daily basis and
of course custom dashboards can always
be built beyond beyond what we already
provide it's as the first version or
something like that so that's pretty
much it way I wanted to talk about this
as our as our sort of evolving
experiment and sort of how we're
thinking of building in the upcoming
months we're sort of adding more changes
to the infrastructure we're adding air
flow we're doing all these smart changes
and some of the Presto stuff so some of
some of this might be inherently solved
because of the changes we're doing but
at least on the basic level we want to
implement something like this - - and
for some lineage in lineage context we
want it we want to gain so if you if
you're doing a similar problem I'd love
to talk to you and gain your perspective
of how how you're doing things and what
kind of roadblocks you've hit so that we
can understand and do things better and
maybe it's something we're missing
totally that that'd be good to know so
thank you for listening and this is our
blog you feel free to look it up careers
page and feel free to reach out to me if
you have any questions thank you hi
maybe maybe maybe I missed it but I was
wondering how you caught every read and
write event do you have something that
intercepts those events like a daemon of
some sort or so in the read side let's
say we can there's few approaches that
we're thinking we we haven't actually
done the read side we've done the right
side but we're thinking like tapping
into the the input format and the record
reader right down below and spark let's
say where we're actually doing a
different approach on the park' side
adding a new input format so if we if we
wrap that up to a different input format
we could always touch the record reader
and capture the information from what
we're touching beyond that we already
have enough clients that oh let's say
you're grabbing some sort of data frame
you have enough information from the
data from the database name and the
table name and then you can infer from
there and most of the the changes around
the
themselves and the the ecosystem
themselves like touching the Metis tour
touching spark would give you some of
that references about what what job or
which which particular users running
that so that's sort of one way we're
thinking of inferring some of that yeah
you mentioned a library or a tool that
turned the raw files and the hive tables
where's there something particular that
you were using to do that
that's our in-house tool like we're just
writing writing into s3 and it's
converting it into partitions and then
educated to tables you said you were
using a ec2 abstraction easy to
abstraction framework or library ECS no
yeah but you see oh you're using ECS
okay I thought I heard like something
like froze fratello or something yes
that's our execution framework that's
sort of an abstraction erase yes is that
is nothing to nor open is open source
it's called flotilla OS on github so
you'll find it here and lo ok la boîte
ela flotilla okay think of ships yes Oh
check it out Thanks
[Music]